ça va tu as eu tous les six d'or wesley
wade 12
le coq en pis
[Musique]
arrivée en australie des dettes énormes
très belle d'une couleur beaucoup plus
pâle que celle-là élabore les appliquant
eh bien je crois que j'appelais
l'auberge y ait une forme régulière ou
non je vais jusqu'à loupé oui très
finement ses produits c'est ce qu'a noté
les bananes on a des termes en cuisine
vous assure enfin il ya toujours cette
envie dévoyer la présence de deux c'est
comme l'eau ce n'est pas de quai
pourrait de langoustines nous sommes
hébergés en principe être enlevé des
gorges et c'est ça alors le terme est
excellent pour les maîtres des relèves
lp vous êtes glossaire et je pense que
je pourrais vous intéresser avec un je
ne sais quel maï-maï aux durs de
récipients c'est un récipient campagnard
de camping savez dans une très grande
dignité
elle nous met une homogénéité j'avais
pas ces matériels à des intentions aller
se promener donc attendez-vous on ne
sait toujours avoir sur votre écran
une recette hawaïenne août haïtienne où
je ne sais quelle que de kangourou à
l'australienne
[Musique]